uh i just want to start with congrats on
the series i finished it yesterday i uh
the best thing i can say is that when it
ended and there was a tease of more i
was very happy
oh well that's good to hear yeah yeah
yeah i think people are watching yeah
they're a little confused because
um
[Music]
season in fact the arc of season one
is
the six episodes are not season one
twelve episodes of season one which is
slow horses and deadlines and it gets i
know some people have
been a little confused by that so
there's more to come there's that yeah
we have a whole another six in the can
yeah there's a trailer at the end of the
first six for the for the next six and i
was very happy i was like i'm ready for
those episodes now please you know hook
me up
um actually
when when you guys signed on to do this
was it um
is there talk of actually doing more
than the 12 that you've done or was it
always just we're going to do these 12
and that's that
well i think like any uh
i mean we we've we've got an advantage
in as much that there are
eight eight nine books of mix and and um
whether
you know more people like you say i
can't wait for the next i can't wait for
the next six or i can't wait for the
next
series i think that's all to be
determined whether we
i mean the books are there
um
and i guess we're we're waiting to hear
get a green light from upstairs whether
we
whether whether we do
more but um
they they're it's a wonderful series of
of
of books and um
you know more adventures of uh
lamb and river and the slow horses so we
just uh we would love to i'd love to we
would love to do more but we didn't
there's not we contractually we didn't
sort of sign up for
we're waiting to waiting to know
yeah
jack talk a little bit about uh either
the opening of episode one has a
fantastic action set piece what was it
like actually filming this thing because
you're filming you know at i believe you
filmed at heathrow
uh we didn't actually we ended up
filming at stansted airport um outside
london um which uh
i think that was to do with the pandemic
and things like that yeah um
but we did they gave us free reign of a
whole section of tarmac and the terminal
buildings and
how we even had a plane that was flown
in especially for us to go in and out
you know up and down from it was just
ridiculous and then i got to run
along uh
underneath
the fuselages of planes and things like
that so it was just pretty unbelievable
to be honest
to be allowed to do that
and incredible fun it was about a week
in the summer that we shot that and it
was uh yeah it was extraordinary to see
we i mean
you know the pen the pandemic
it
had you know
its problems because
there's a lot of um
originally i think the sequence was
going to be shot at heathrow and we
which was amazing because you there was
a whole terminal
that that they were allowed to use
um and then because of the pandemic and
and delays in when we started shooting
and and um i know that the director
would say sometimes
oh you know we'd turn up at a location
and he would say this is the third
location
we've we've already lost
two locations so it was a tricky i think
it was a tricky thing because you know
you you you wrecky something
and you have an image of how the whole
thing is going to play out in this
particular space
and then the production come along and
say you've lost that space
now we need to look at a new one and
then you look at a new one
and then you work all it out or you
storyboard it and then they come and say
no we've lost that and now we're looking
at a third location so it was it was
um it was it was a
fun show to make
but it was at the very very height of
covid so
there were you know the weigh-in on a
set a particular way out of the set
there was bubble a bubble b
they they really they handled
and maneuvered around the the covid
brilliantly yeah
yeah i um i also one of the things i
love about the show one of the many
things besides your guys's performances
is that normally with a spy show you are
watching the best of the best and
instead this is not the best of the best
and you have these characters with these
weird idiots like it's just um for both
of you though what was it about this
show that said i want to be a part of
this i need to do this well i i for me i
think exactly that this is the what this
is the wonderful thing that mick heron
who wrote the books has done he's given
you a very familiar world that we that
we kind of will recognize
but you know where where the sort of
character like james bond is almost like
a super
he's almost like a superhero
we give you the world of espionage and
then characters that the
ordinary people on the street can relate
to they've all
they're flawed they've
um
that that's that's i think
the
the great the great thing about the
writing is that
it is
it's peopled with
these characters
that i think the audience can
um connect with
no it was um
it was just a sort of
no-brainer that i i would i wanted to be
considered and i work really hard to be
considered for this because it was just
a beautiful
concept and a perfect concept uh and
very much my sense of humor um and
anything that has any remotely any kind
of humor
which i'm always desperate to do but
also knowing that i'll spend a large
part of the time trying not to laugh
myself which is exactly what happened on
this i was just constantly trying not to
laugh um because it's shoved up against
very hardly shoved up against um
quite serious topics and serious
situations which just makes it even
funnier for me to be honest
yeah on that note um uh your speed
dating ends with me um i want to say
thank you and uh seriously man uh guys
congratulations uh i thought this the
series is fantastic can't wait to watch
more love the t-shirt
might have been worn on purpose
[Laughter]
you